[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment
bon beaucoup d'enthousiasmé champ
j'attendais en charmeur moi c'est le
transfert de l'été un sérieux puisque
vous étiez sur direct 8 où il est
maintenant sur d8 comment ça va ça se
passe bien ça va bien ça va bien on va
essayer de d'être je vous suis pas je
vous sens pour les séries c'est que vous
pouvez le mettre enfin parce que vous
pouvez leur mettre un petit peu dans son
environnement de direct8 l'année
dernière s'il vous plaît vous avez le
kit d vite s'il vous plaît voilà
[Applaudissements]
les habitants commencent à l'église
jeanne vous était l'invité de thierry
ardisson sur canal pour salut les
terriens et surtout pour assurer la
promo de cette merveilleuse émission qui
touche pas à mon poste j'ai regardé par
conscience professionnelle et on va pas
se mentir ras rien à signaler
vous avez fait le job des vannes des
punchline et vas-y que j'embrasse
roselyne bachelot on l'a vu tout à
l'heure j'ai vu il est bien mais le
problème mais c'est ça vous m'avez venir
le problème européen car il ya un
problème c'est que quand on est invité
de salut les terriens ben faut rester
jusqu'à la fin c'est ça rené dosière
bonsoir bonsoir vous venez de publier
l'état au régime aux éditions du seuil
le dernier de vos livres consacrés à
l'argent public
voilà cyril vous avez donc dû assister à
la paix deux spéciales impôts et
gaspillage qui mêle la p3 sa fin qui
avait l'appui 3 un débat passionné et
passionnant surtout pour vous syrie là
je crois pouvoir des images
intercommunalités et communes 743
milliards d'euros azur alors c'est
énorme
et donc si le risque augmente noisy a
fait facilement
[Musique]
le droit biya
[Applaudissements]
les visages que vous avez choper de
cyril c'est quand même très fort ce qui
fait dans ce visage parce que c'est je
m'ennuie mais il faut pas que j'ai peur
de m'ennuyer
donc il ya même un air de dire on sait
pas tout à fait à ce qui se passe en rdc
patron d'atout vérifier les chiffres ça
genre ouais enfin faut vérifier quand
même assez fort c'est que ça